so now we have a really efficient method
of doing multiple pattern matching using
the burrows-wheeler transform but I want
us to recall that finding exact pattern
matches is not what our original goal
was we want to find places where your
individual genome has variants when
compared to the reference genome so we
need to look for in exact matching in
order to find these variants so if we
have a single pattern representing a
single read then we want to find all
positions in the genome where this
pattern occurs with say at most D miss
mattress and this is a problem that we
saw at the first part of the course the
approximate pattern matching problem now
again we simply want to generalize this
to the case where we have multiple
patterns a collection of reads and we
want to match each of these against the
genome to find where they occur with at
most D mismatches there going to be two
methods I'll show you to show you kind
of the highlights of how you could
extend the methods that we already have
for exact pattern matching towards
approximate pattern matching so the
first one is say that we know that a
pattern appears in the genome with
exactly one mismatch so here's a pattern
and hypothetical genome and here's a
mismatch if you divide the pattern into
two pieces then notice that one side is
going to have to match the genome
exactly so here the mismatch was on the
left side of the partition and so the
right side has to match exactly if the
mismatch were on the right side the left
side would have to match exactly in
general if you have a pattern that
occurs in the genome would say D
mismatches then you're going to be able
to divide that pattern into D plus 1
approximately equal pieces and then
you're going to be able to find at least
one of those pieces that matches the
genome exactly there so to give you an
example here's a string of I just wrote
X's of length 35 and say that we have
six mismatches with the genome so I've
labeled just random locations where it
could mismatch and if you partition this
into seven pieces then we have six
minutes matches partition these strings
into seven pieces of equal length here
would be length five and then notice the
that you have a mismatch in every one of
these windows except for this one okay
and so here we're going to have an exact
match with the genome and so this is
going to be generalizable so that
whenever you have D mismatches if you
divide this pattern into D plus one
pieces you'll have at least one of these
smaller strings exactly match the genome
so this sets up a method called C
seating if you're looking for D
mismatches you can divide each of your
pattern strings into D plus one small or
approximately equal pieces and these
pieces are called seeds and then you
look for exact matches of those seeds
with your genome once you find those
exact matches it narrows down what you
have to consider a lot so you can throw
out a lot of your patterns and then look
for in exact matches based off of those
seed matches so if you say we did find a
seed match
well let's maybe look at that location
and see and count the number of in exact
matches or mismatches that we see so
that's really just a very
straightforward way of thinking about
pattern matching another way would be to
integrate a direct burrows-wheeler
approach so I'll show you an example of
how this might work recall that when we
when we looked at pattern matching
before with burrows-wheeler we searched
for a na and panama bananas and so we
started by saying let's walk backwards
through this pattern so we started with
finding the A's and we walk backwards to
the other column of the burrows-wheeler
matrix and before we said okay we could
find three ends so we were walking
backward in the pattern so we had an A
and then an N and we would immediately
eliminate the M the P and the B because
they didn't match the end that we were
looking for so if we are allowing say
one mismatch or at most one mismatch
then we need to keep these red letters
around all right we need to hold on to
them because it may be the case that we
can continue extending and get exact
matches everywhere else and then we
would have an inexact match with one
mismatch so what we'll need to do then
is we'll need to keep track of the
number of mismatches that we've
encountered along the way so here we've
encountered zero mismatches when we've
matched these ends because we have to
match symbols here we've encountered one
mismatch that the M Nepean
be and then because we haven't exceeded
one mismatch we'll need to extend all
these strings okay
so we'll use the first last property and
take all of find where each of these
elements occurs back in the first column
and then we'll say well we know that the
a is going to be there next okay now we
carry the mismatches down and we see
okay we have one mismatch here here and
here
and then we need to walk backwards again
towards the next symbol in the pattern
string Anna here we see that we have
five occurrences of a all right so we're
able to extend each of these five
pattern candidates backwards and and
have a match of a in this case we walk
backwards to the last column of the
burrows-wheeler matrix and we hit the
dollar sign so that says that we've
essentially wrapped around the string or
you can think of it as a mismatch but
we've wrapped around the string and so
now we need to eliminate this okay so we
now have when we go suffers last
property and go backwards with these
five matches we get five inexact matches
with one at most one mismatch in our
string so we've kept track that we have
one mismatch here one mismatch here and
then we have the three perfect matches
that we found before so then we say
where are they well we use a suffix
array or a partial suffix array we
already know how to find where these
mismatch where these in exact matches
occurred we know that they occurred at
position starting position five that's a
match one mismatch starting position
three we can find a ma which has one
mismatch and then starting positions one
seven and nine give us the exact matches
that we saw before so just being able to
solve the exact multiple pattern
matching problem is going to be able to
give us we now have this huge arsenal of
power using burrows-wheeler that were
able to easily step forward and deal
with in exact matches now